president trump is pushing back on
speculation he
suffered a major health issue last fall
when he made a surprise visit to walter
reed medical center
he's denying he had several mini strokes
a specific allegation nobody had
actually made
before he brought it up ben tracy has
more from the white house
president trump on tuesday tried to
squash any rumors about his health
in multiple tweets he called speculation
that he suffered a series of mini
strokes
fake news he's referring to this news
cameras followed the presidential
motorcade last november as it departed
the white house
for an unscheduled trip to the hospital
president trump was there for more than
two hours that day
he later tweeted this explanation
visited a great family of a young man
under major surgery also began phase one
of my yearly physical
but the president's routine medical
checkup is typically announced ahead of
time and according to a new book from
new york times washington correspondent
michael schmidt
in the hours leading up to that hospital
trip vice president pence was allegedly
asked to be on standby
to take over the powers of the
presidency temporarily
in case president trump needed a
procedure requiring anesthesia
there was nothing out of the ordinary
about that moment or that day
vice president pence addressed the
claims last night
i don't recall being told to be on
standby i
i was informed that the president had a
doctor's appointment i got to tell you
and part of this job is you're always on
standby as your vice president of the
united states
it's worth repeating that schmidt's new
book never mentions anything about mini
strokes the white house now claims that
president trump was actually responding
to a tweet by former clinton press
secretary joe lockhart
who had questioned whether the president
had a stroke
president trump then directed his
physician to put out a statement saying
that the president's never been
treated rather and or evaluated for a
stroke
anthony ben the cdc just announced a
moratorium on evictions for most
renters through the end of the year i
think some people might be surprised it
came from the centers for disease
control what can you tell us
about that order yeah so the reason it
came from the cdc is they say this is
needed to slow the spread of coronavirus
they want to avoid having a bunch of
people who get evicted ending up in
homeless shelters
or other crowded living situations now
to apply for this new rental moratorium
renters will have to be facing a
substantial loss of income
the inability to pay their full rent and
show their best efforts to pay their
partial rent
now those who apply also need to show
that eviction would leave them homeless
or forced to live closely with others
this does not relieve tenants of their
ultimate obligation to pay their rent
and only applies to individuals making
less than 99 thousand dollars a year
or twice twice that for joint filers
now this plan does replace a moratorium
that was passed by congress
and expired back in july it's estimated
that millions could face
eviction without more government help
anthony ben tracy thank you ben